whenever someone starts using personal
names and screaming like a lunatic
they're losing the debate let me Remain
the Palestinians the Palestinians the
Palestinians the the Palestinians were
offered to state in 1936 in the appeal
commission they rejected it they were
offered to state in 1947 the UN
partition plan they rejected it they
were offered to state in 1967 after
Israel conquered Judean Samar and the
West Bank they rejected it they were
offered to state in 2000 yasar a Barack
they rejected it you are a Jew hater
defined as someone who only want to lie
and say that the Jews are
genoci whenever someone starts using
personal names and screaming like a
lunatic they're losing the debate
everything that the rabbi said there was
true that the 1936 peel commission 1947
partition plan 67 after that War uh 2000
2008 there were so many times that the
Palestinians could have had a state